und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend zu den vielen spezialitäten des
black city drummers gehört auch welche
rasante rollen tauschte sich in diesen
tagen in london beobachten lassen
vom rebell zum regenten und umgekehrt
erst waren boris johnson und seine leute
die rebellen jetzt sind es plötzlich die
anderen darunter prominente ehemalige
regierungsmitglieder 21 konservative
abgeordnete hat johnson aus seiner
fraktion heraus geworfen was so in der
form im deutschen bundestag übrigens
nicht denkbar wären mehr gemetzel
jedenfalls geht kaum
boris johnson so viel steht fest spielt
mit hohem risiko und er sucht jetzt
schon nach schuldigen für das fiasko das
sich am horizont abzeichnet was ich
heute abend im parlament abspielte
berichtet yasin herrlein boris johnson
ist ein mann der mit worten umgehen kann
daran besteht kein zweifel entsprechend
groß ist auch sein repertoire den
begriff feigling zu umschreiben
beim ersten mal muss man genau hinhören
so laut war es im unterhaus er sei eine
big girls klaus raunte johnson dem
oppositionsführer entgegen die bluse
eines dicken mädchens auch feige ist
laut dem englischen sprachgebrauch das
huhn
hier gibt es nur einen flur bad
behandeltes hühnchen und das sitzt mir
gegenüber
das war einerseits eine anspielung auf
corbijns warnung dass ein handels deal
mit den usa im kurbad malträtierte
hühnchen auf den tisch bringen und
andererseits ein beweis der zunehmenden
verrohung der sitten im parlament und
alles nur weil die leber partei sich
weigert auf johnsons plan einzugehen am
15 oktober neuwahlen abzuhalten
und noch etwas verdeutlicht wie sich der
wind gedreht hat im unterhaus dieser
zwischenruf eines abgeordneten in bezug
auf einen von johnson vor einigen wochen
geäußerten kommentar verschleierte
muslimische frauen sehen aus wie
briefkästen oder bankräuber wird der
premierminister sich endlich
entschuldigen für seine herabwürdigenden
und rassistischen bemerkungen
lang anhaltender applaus der ton wird
rauer und das alte wort von den
konservativen als die garstige partei
macht wieder die runde
vor allem auch seit der premiere jene
gemäßigten die gestern gegen ihn
gestimmt hatten aus der fraktion
ausgeschlossen hat darunter den
dienstältesten abgeordneten und
ehemaligen finanzminister ken clarke und
den enkel winston churchills hier als
kleiner junge an der hand von boris
johnsons großen vorbild es ist töricht
an unsere potenziellen wähler die
nachricht auszusenden dass diese partei
für jedermann nun zu einer kleinen sekte
verkommen ist ein nachspiel hatte heute
auch diese szene von gestern der sich
auf der regierungsbank hin pflegende
minister für parlaments fragen jacob wie
smoke während der debatte jene arroganz
die man wie smoke vor wird begegnete das
parlament jetzt mit der verabschiedung
des gesetzes gegen den dreck sind ohne
abkommen am späten abend wird es dem
house of lords vorgelegt johnson kontert
mit einem antrag auf neuwahlen am 15
oktober
dazu braucht er zunächst eine zwei
drittel mehrheit die er aber nicht
bekommen wird solange das modell gesetzt
und stichfest ist dennoch neuwahl über
kurz oder lang scheinen der einzige
ausweg aus der praxis sackgasse
ich hab es geht hoch her diana
zimmermann in london das unterhaus hat
also jetzt das gesetz zur verhinderung
eines new deal drexhage angenommen
welche optionen hat boris johnson denn
jetzt noch die erste option die er
gewählt hat relativ ungewöhnlich für den
regierungschef eines demokratischen
landes ist zu sagen dass er dieses
gesetz vom unterhaus beschlossen nicht
respektieren wird er weigert sich das
von ihm so genannte kapitulation gesetz
nach brüssel zu bringen und dort um eine
verschiebung des brh exit datums
anzufragen
das einzige was ihn jetzt noch bleibt
sind neuwahlen dafür allerdings braucht
er die zustimmung des parlaments und die
opposition hat schon sehr deutlich
angekündigt dass sie heute abend diese
zustimmung verweigern wird sie möchte er
ist dass dieses gesetz zur verschiebung
wirklich alle etappen der gesetzgebung
passiert hat durch das oberhaus gekommen
ist und wirklich ein stein gemeißelt ist
bevor sie boris johnson neuwahlen
zustimmt und das ganze könnte sich also
noch ein paar tage hinziehen sagt kratz
johnson will neuwahlen oder besser
gesagt er braucht neuwahlen aber kann
sich denn eigentlich so sicher sein dass
er daraus dann auch gestärkt hervorgehen
wird natürlich nicht das sind ja
demokratische wahlen und die letzte
regierungschefin die dachte es ist
kinderleicht eine konservative mehrheit
im parlament auszubauen war johnstons
vorgängerin theresa may 2017 statt der
etwa 100 erträumten zusätzlichen sitze
allerdings hat sie die absolute mehrheit
der konservativen damals verspielt hatte
dann nicht mehr genug rückhalt im
parlament um den mit der eu
ausgehandelten dragset irrt durch zu
bekommen und wäre die sache anders
gelaufen dann stünden wir heute wohl
nicht hier unterbrechen wäre schon
geschehen
johnson braucht die waren jetzt
tatsächlich das ist er kein luxus
sondern einfacher notwendigkeit
unterstützt sich bei seinem optimismus
auf zweierlei erstens auf sein eigenes
selbstvertrauen und zweitens auf die
schwäche seiner gegner
die labour partei hat unter jeremy copp
in den letzten drei jahren einen
schlingerkurs in sachen dragset
hingelegt der sie sehr viel
glaubwürdigkeit gekostet hat und das
andere problem der opposition ist dass
die exit gegnerischen stimmen sich auf
fünf parteien verteilen
das ist beim hiesigen mehrheitswahlrecht
sich ein erheblicher vorteil für johnson
die entscheidende frage wird trotzdem
sagen ist das brachiale verhalten dass
johnson an den tag legt für konservative
wähler attraktiv und zweitens wie viele
briten wollen den br- exit um jeden
preis wirklich noch dankeschön diana
zimmermann nach london
viele informationen und hintergründe zum
exit chaos und großbritannien finden sie
auch online auf heute.de gegen die
innerparteiliche verwerfungen bei den
britischen konservativen sind die
konflikte bei den deutschen
sozialdemokraten ja geradezu ein
freundliches ringelpiez mit anfassen
apropos brille reigen 17 kandidaten
bewarben sich um den parteivorsitz bis
auf einen treten sie jeweils paarweise
an zwei haben auf der ersten casting
veranstaltung heute zurückgezogen da
waren es nur noch 15
was ja auch noch ein reichlich großes
feld ist dass da jetzt eine deutschland
tour startet von der sich die spd so wie
erhofft
das bo und andreas huppert haben den
auftakt in saarbrücken beobachtet
stunden vor der ersten regionalkonferenz
läuft alles noch nach plan
acht kandidaten paare und ein
einzelbewerber stellen sich wohl gelaunt
und optimistisch der presse am abend
dann die erste überraschung auf der
roadshow der spd ein paar zieht sich
bereits zurück wir haben uns nach langer
intensiver debatte entschieden dass wir
unsere kraft aus unserer kandidatur mit
all unseren unterstützern übergehen
lassen wollen in das team von murat und
saskia
da waren es also nur noch 15 die
spd-vorsitzende werden wollten und die
die gesteigerten erwartungen der basis
erfüllen muss das wird eine
entscheidende frage für die spd sein ob
sie sich jetzt in der coco erneuern
möchte und zeigen möchte hier in der
groko wir können mit realpolitik was
anfangen oder ob sie sagten nein wir
gehen aus dieser gruppe heraus diese
kroko hat uns herr abgezogen sie muss
linker werden muss wieder die die grund
gene der spd soziale gerechtigkeit
wieder mehr in den vordergrund schieben
linker werden raus aus der gruppe
positionen die auch von der mehrheit der
kandidaten getragen werden so auch die
forderung nach größerer
verteilungsgerechtigkeit stichwort
vermögenssteuer
lasst uns offensiv für eine
vermögenssteuer eine erbschaftssteuer
auch für eine anhebung des
spitzensteuersatzes kämpfen verfügung
das sozialdemokratische
selbstbewusstsein hat vor allem in der
großen koalition deutlich schaden
genommen basis und kandidaten fordern
wieder mehr rückgrat
wenn wir unsere eigenen erfolge nicht
feiern wenn ich selber den mut und die
zuversicht haben zu sagen jawohl das ist
unser erfolg und ohne
regierungsbeteiligung hätten wir das
nicht durchgesetzt da tut es keiner
liebe genossen beim thema
glaubwürdigkeit bekommt der
prominenteste bewerber sein fett weg man
mit glaubwürdigkeit jemanden erklären
dass derjenige der uns letzten endes
auch maßgeblich beteiligt in funktion in
dieses tal der tränen
diesen niederungen der heutigen ergebnis
geführt hat heute zukünftig für
glaubwürdigkeit und soziale
gerechtigkeit in der spd steht zwischen
erklärungs problem ich bin der meinung
dass sich ein echter truly
sozialdemokrat binden
der start der spd roadshow hat
überraschungen kontroversen und einige
phrasen gebracht 22 regionalkonferenzen
folgen noch die spd eine partei auf der
suche nach neuen vorsitzenden
beschlossen haid und irgendwie auch nach
sich selbst diese art der vorsitzende
suche bleibt ein experiment mit offenem
ausgang
und dann blicken wir jetzt erstmal ins
ausland in die usa
wirbelsturm dorian bewegt sich derzeit
auf die amerikanische ostküste zu aber
deutlich abgeschwächt
in florida ist er bereits vorbei gezogen
ohne aufladen zu schlagen was der herr
iken hingegen auf den bahamas
angerichtet hat das wird jetzt in vollem
ausmaß sichtbar einen so kräftigen
wirbelsturm hat die karibische
inselgruppe vermutlich noch nie
heimgesucht das schlimmer war dass er so
langsam über die inseln hinweg zog und
dabei so enorm viel regen ab hut auf
flachen land das nur wenige meter über
dem meeresspiegel liegt harry kalorien
vom aller ausgesehen
aufgenommen aus 400 kilometern höhe von
der raumstation iss faszinierend von
hier so weit oben aber voller
zerstörungskraft weiter unten
das inselparadies great abaco island im
nördlichen teil der bahamas ist jetzt
ein trümmerfeld den
windgeschwindigkeiten von 300 kilometern
pro stunde konnte kaum etwas standhalten
mehr als die hälfte aller häuser sind
dem erdboden gleich gemacht sie haben
überlebt manche von ihnen haben aber
nicht nur ihr heim verloren
meine frau stand auf dem küchenschrank
er ist zusammengekracht und dann ich
blieb bei ihr dann ist sie ertrunken
rund 60.000 menschen brauchen hilfe
die us-küstenwache rettet bereits mit
hubschraubern verletzte andere
einsatzkräfte können wegen des
schlechten wetters und der überflutungen
erst nach und nach zu den betroffenen
nicht nur mit medikamenten lebensmitteln
und kleidung
sie brauchen jedes stück hilfe dass sie
kriegen können
es ist verheerend herz reißen wir haben
zusätzlich neben den teams für das
körperliche wohl auch ein team zur
psychologischen unterstützung für sie
weil sie so viel durchgemacht haben
unterstützung für die bahamas verspricht
heute auch der us präsident
wir haben einige helikopter und
verschicken leute um ihnen zu helfen
sie brauchen große hilfe denn das was da
passiert ist unglaublich
an der ostküste der usa haben derweil
hunderttausende in notunterkünften aus
florida ist glimpflich davon gekommen
aber dorian könnte haus oder north
carolina treffen abgeschwächt auf stufe
2 von 5 doch die regenmassen und
windgeschwindigkeiten von rund 165
kilometern pro stunde bleiben gefährlich
tom pollock berichtet und mit dem thema
tierschutz beginnen jetzt die
nachrichten hat das bundeskabinett hat
ein agrar paket auf den weg gebracht
vorgesehen sind unter anderem ein neues
freiwilliges tierwohl kennzeichen im
supermarkt und mehr schutz für insekten
das kabinett beschloss dass der einsatz
von unkraut und schädlings giften
insgesamt stark eingeschränkt werden
soll das umstrittene glyphosat soll ende
2023 verboten werden
der missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung röhre ich hat die
bundesländer aufgefordert mehr in den
schutz von kindern und jugendlichen vor
sexuellem missbrauch zu investieren
kitas schulen sportvereine und andere
einrichtungen bräuchten dringend mehr
unterstützung für ihr engagement gegen
sexuelle gewalt sagt röhrig in berlin
anders war die vorstellung eines
berichts des deutschen jugendinstituts
demnach geht etwa die mehrheit der
befragten kitas und schulen selbst davon
aus dass sie kein umfassendes
schutzkonzept haben
in italien steht die neue
regierungsmannschaft morgen soll sie
vereidigt werden
ministerpräsident habe konnte hat eine
koalition aus der populistischen fünf
sterne bewegung und den sozialdemokraten
gebildet
die stellte er heute präsidentielle
material vor
der chef der fünf sterne bewegung mayo
soll neuer außenminister werden
iran macht seine drohung wahr und zieht
sich weiter aus den verpflichtungen des
internationalen atom abkommens zurück
präsident roh hanni verkündete am abend
in einer fernsehansprache entwicklung
und forschung in der atomtechnologie
würden wieder ohne einschränkungen
aufgenommen
johanni hat er eine solche entscheidung
bereits angekündigt nachdem er die
zusagen der europäer für sanktions
erleichterungen als unzureichend
kritisiert hat
in hongkong haben die wochenlangen
demonstrationen wirkung gezeigt das
gesetz für auslieferungen in china wird
endgültig gestoppt regierungschefin lahm
erklärte den gesetzentwurf offiziell für
nichtig und sie appellierte an die
demonstranten mit der regierung in
dialog zu treten
die demokratiebewegung genügt diese
entscheidung aber nicht sie fordert eine
unabhängige untersuchung der
polizeigewalt gegen demonstranten und
eine amnestie für die inhaftierten
aktivisten und oppositionspolitiker
das lateinische wörtchen ex kennt man ja
aus vielen zusammenhängen ex-frau ex
freund oder ex-minister ex was auch
immer ex auf latein aus in der
finanzwelt hat ex zusätzlich die
bedeutung ohne das gegenstück ist das
lateinische com mit mit oder ohne kummer
oder ex so kommt dieser eigentümliche
begriff comex geschäfte zustande den man
früher nur in fachkreisen kannte der
aber inzwischen ja äußerst prominent
geworden ist denn diese trickreichen
aktienverkäufe mit oder ohne dividende
stehen für einen der größten
finanzskandale der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte durch comics sowie
auch geschäfte sollen dem deutschen
staat steuereinnahmen von insgesamt mehr
als 30 milliarden euro entgangen sein
bevor wir gleich zum prozessauftakt
gegen zwei angeklagte kommen erklärt
christian von rechenberg noch mal ganz
kurz worum es dabei geht
compex geschäftet ist wie pingpong
schauen in dieser geschwindigkeit
kommste nicht mehr mit so was klappt
auch bei wertpapieren wenn man sie
elektronisch handelt schnell und
raffiniert hin und her schiebt bis einer
den überblick verliert vater staat und
das ist ja das gewünschte ziel bei
comics investor hat aktien eines
unternehmens
dem geht es gut es schüttet gewinne aus
die dividende auf die mooser
kapitalertragssteuer zahlen die er sich
später aber zurück holen darf nun der
trick das aktienpaket wird rund um den
dividenden tag so lange rasch
weiterverkauft bis man es nicht mehr
verfolgen kann
jetzt können andere beteiligte dem start
vorgaukeln auch sie besitzen diese
aktien
um sich dann kapitalertragsteuer
zurückzuholen die sie nie gezahlt haben
ein steuerschlupfloch geschlossen vor
sieben jahren die fälle davor
beschäftigen die justiz ob das spiel mit
der geschwindigkeit damals legal war
oder eben nicht in bonn begann heute der
strafprozess gegen zwei ehemalige
aktienhändler oder passender gesagt ex
aktienhändler
allein durch ihre geschäfte sollen den
deutschen staatskassen 440 millionen
euro im gang seien
dabei wird es nicht nur darum gehen was
sie taten sondern auch inwieweit das zum
damaligen zeitpunkt strafbar war dort
ferber berichtet es ist ein prozess mit
guten anzügen männer aus der welt der
banken und broker stehen vom landgericht
bonn
zwei angeklagte denen ein steuerschaden
von 440 millionen euro zur last gelegt
wird verursacht durch tricks beim
aktienhandel
es ist ein beispielhafter prozess denn
es gibt weitere ermittlungen in
verschiedenen verfahren gegen 200
personen die comics vermarktung liege im
großen stil bei vielen banken mit vielen
produkten
ich glaube dass das comics vielleicht
der grösste steuer skandal in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik ist mit
mit comex und ähnlich steuer getriebenen
aktiengeschäft ist unseren recherchen
nach den schaden von über 32 milliarden
entstanden
die beiden angeklagten briten in bonn
sind auch kronzeugen sie haben ausgesagt
aber ihre beteiligung an den comics
geschäften
dabei hat comics so viel sagen experten
immer viele beteiligte sind netzwerke
von tätern die gemeinsam es geschafft
haben dem steuerzahler geld aus der
tasche zu ziehen
ein einzelner hätte das nicht machen
können das ist handelt sich um
komplizierte finanztransaktionen für die
wanten hängt vom ausgang des prozesses
in bonn viel ab sie haben dutzende von
anwälten als beobachter geschickt sie
fürchten regressforderungen auch die
politik beobachtet den prozess wie ich
die banken jahr lang machen selbst wenn
es lücken in gesetzen gegeben hat was
schlimm wäre und schlecht dann ist das
immer noch kein grund zu sagen ja dann
hab ich doch allen alles recht mich
daran zu bedienen denn es geht bei
comics genau um diese gesetzeslücke
gesetzeslücken die banken
wirtschaftsprüfer anwälte ausgenutzt
haben
die politik überfordert es gibt auf der
einen seite ein richtiges
organisationsversagen im bereich des
finanzministeriums sowohl unter peer
steinbrück als auch unter wolfgang
schäuble die verschiedenen experten habe
nicht zusammen gearbeitet und die
finanzaufsicht sagt das hat mit steuern
zu tun das geht uns doch nichts an und
die steuerleute wussten aber nicht was
am finanzmarkt passiert die hätten
zusammen arbeiten müssen und das ist
natürlich die verantwortung des
ministers so etwas zu organisieren was
die politik versäumt hat soll die justiz
nun richten das urteil wird frühestens
im januar erwartet
und jetzt nochmal eins mit anderen
themen
die designierte präsidentin der
europäischen zentralbank christine
lagarde war heute in einem ausschuss des
europaparlaments und hat erklärt welche
geldpolitik sie verfolgen will wenn sie
im november mario draghi ablöst frank
bethmann
wie sieht frau lagarde die aktuelle
linie tiefer zinsen und offener
geldschleusen ja ein problem scheint sie
damit nicht zu haben die finanzmärkte
gehen bereits seit juli seit bekannt ist
dass lagarde die neue ezb-präsident in
werden soll davon aus dass die französin
den kurs ihres vorgängers mario draghi
fortsetzen wird und diese erwartungen
hat sie heute in brüssel bestätigt die
inflation ist weiter zu niedrig ich
stimme mit dem ezb-rat darin überein
dass die geldpolitik noch für einen
längeren zeitraum locker bleiben muss
unter umständen das klang heute bei
lagarde durch ist sie sogar bereit die
geldschleusen noch weiter zu öffnen
selbst wenn das ungewünschte
nebeneffekte hätte wie sie einräumt denn
die herausforderungen die den kurs der
ezb rechtfertigen sind nicht kleiner
geworden
die zinsen könnten also auf lange zeit
sehr niedrig bleiben insbesondere
deutschland ist dieser kurs umstritten
genauso wie madame lagarde selbst in
ihrem noch amt als chefin des
internationalen währungsfonds iwf hat
sie immer wieder mehr investitionen von
den staaten gefordert insbesondere von
der bundesregierung investitionen um die
konjunktur anzukurbeln
in neuer funktion wird er holte sie
heute ihr mantra die staaten sollten
ihren spielraum nutzen
sinngemäß die ezb können nur dafür
sorgen dass geld günstig bleibe
investieren müssten die regierungen in
berlin dürfte man sich abermals
angesprochen gefühlt haben frank
bethmann vielen dank gerne der deutsche
modefotograf peter lindbergh ist tot er
starb gestern im alter von 74 jahren in
seiner wahlheimat paris
in den 90er jahren prägte er mit seinen
modeaufnahmen das phänomen supermodel
naomi campbell linda evangelista als top
stars nicht bloß als trägerinnen neuer
kleider
zugleich suchte er immer den blick
hinter die fassade und versucht er das
einzigartige eines menschen zu ergründen
und festzuhalten
die staatsanwaltschaft hamburg führt ein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen den
ehemaligen fußball-nationalspieler
christoph metzelder
sie prüft den verdacht der verbreitung
kinderpornografischen materials
gestern hatten ermittler sein haus in
düsseldorf durchsucht das
sichergestellte material werde derzeit
ausgewertet sagte eine sprecherin der
staatsanwaltschaft
metzelder soll einer frau in hamburg
über eine kommunikationsplattform
kinderpornografische bilder geschickt
haben
zu den vorwürfen hat sich der
langjährige bundesliga-profi bislang
nicht geäußert die ard für die metzelder
als tv experte tätig ist lässt die
zusammenarbeit vorerst ruhen und jetzt
die zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
27 28 29 34 36 42 superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
ferdinand von schirach ist derzeit der
wohl erfolgreichste deutsche
schriftsteller sein aktuelles buch
kaffee und zigaretten hält sich schon
seit einem halben jahr in den top ten
der bestseller-listen die meiste zeit
auf platz eins was der mann schreibt
wird ihm von den lesern aus den händen
gerissen und gerne auch verfilmt und
nicht nur das sein theaterstück terror
wird auf sämtlichen fünf kontinenten
dieser welt gespielt und dabei hat von
schirach erst mit mitte vierzig
angefangen zu schreiben
davor hat er als anwalt gearbeitet vom
juristen zum star autor also doch
öffentliche auftritte hat
er mag es nicht wenn man ihm zu nahe
kommt unser kultur reporter claudius
armbruster hat ihn mit anderen berühmten
zeitgenossen ins gespräch gebracht und
so ist ein dokumentarfilm entstanden
indem man dann doch sehr viel über
ferdinand von schirach erfahren kann
hier einige ausschnitte warum lesen die
deutschen so gerne chirac nicht nur die
deutschen seine bücher werden ja in der
ganzen welt gelesen
wahrscheinlich weil kaum jemand die
abgründe der menschen ihre ambivalenz so
beschreiben kann wie ferdinand von
schirach
doch ihm in interviews nahezukommen
gelingt selten am besten lernt man ihn
kennen wenn er mit anderen spricht
wir haben ihn begleitet bei begegnungen
mit seinem freund und schriftsteller
kollegen benjamin von stuckrad barre in
venedig mit der influenza in kenia dawns
in berlin und beim treffen mit dem
künstler anselm kiefer in südfrankreich
hier ein kurzer blick in kiefers kunst
universum lange boot das 50 hektar große
atelier gelände auf dem seine werke
entstehen künstlerische beschäftigung
mit deutscher geschichte
kiefer ist 75 und in den ruinen des
krieges aufgewachsen
es ist auch wirklich eine große idee und
das ist kindheit einfach nur das kind
hat das war ja so dass bei den griechen
das erhaben schrecklich war ja das hatte
immer auch einen schrecken sind ja aber
ein kunstwerk muss auf den strecken ganz
genau sonst dekoration ja diese ganzen
kraft zur gestaltung und alles hat es
auch einen schrecken ist unruhe und das
ja es ist bedrohlich in diesem unendlich
schönen abend und das ist so sehr habe
ich habe kinder also fünf aber zwei die
zwei kleinen die sind 16 und 15 jahre
und den habe ich jeden abend ein von
ihren geschichten diese wo die wada die
die verschiedene pferde sind schon eine
hand an der heizung und die frauen
achten strikt weg und die register und
die habe die so gern gehabt habe sagte
von schirach kommen jetzt wieder
geschlossen
aber diese geschichte als gute nacht
geschichten hatten natürlich auch noch
mal ein eigenes und sie haben das
vorgelesen die ich habe erzählt sie habe
es erzählt also naja solange höhere die
nicht zu dass ich außer man ist es nicht
und jetzt jetzt jetzt die bösen wolf das
ist sie zur natur wies kann man ja auch
weit genug weg ich habe wenig romantisch
ist aber es gibt bei den romantikern das
verstummen und das ist dann doch möglich
bei den blick wie schon gesagt ein
kurzer blick ein kurzer ausschnitt aus
einem langen gespräch radikalität und
meisterschaft das vereint die beiden und
das rauchen und der humor
ich brauche eigentlich nur fürs
fernsehen ist natürlich die ganze dunkle
über ferdinand von schirach können sie
heute um 23 uhr 20 auf 3sat sehen oder
jetzt jederzeit online in der zdf
mediathek abrufen
das was wir uns mit dem auslandsjournal
geht es gleich weiter unter anderem mit
einem bericht aus dem amazonas und um 00
55 dann heute plus mit einer brücke auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer es wird zwei
mal etwas regnen aber es ist einfach
viel zu wenig bei uns derzeit überquert
und so eine kleine schwache regenfront
wird deutschland überqueren mit wenigen
regenschauern aber an den alpen entsteht
neuer dauerregen morgen nachmittag vor
allen dingen und schauer von der nordsee
ziehen immer wieder auf in dieser
kühleren luft in den nächsten stunden
immer wieder ein paar schauer die
norddeutschland nach osten überqueren
und in der zweiten nachthälfte wird es
auch im südwesten einzelne schauer geben
morgen in norddeutschland so richtig
herbstliches wetter
wir haben einen stürmischen west bis
nordwestwind dazu immer wieder
regenschauer einzelne gewitter sind
dabei nach osten hin lockert aber mehr
und mehr auf da ist es freundlicher
genauso wie in der mitte deutschland ab
dem erzgebirge dann bis zu den
ereignissen stärker bewölkt ab und zu
regnet und dauerregen stellt sich ein
vom bodensee bis nach passau richtung
rhein allerdings ist es freundlicher und
die temperaturen dann bei dauerregen an
den alpen 15 grad sonst 16 bis 21 und
die wärme steckt noch weiterhin im osten
mit 22 bis 24 grad wechselhaft geht's
weiter freitag sieht erstmal ganz
freundlich aus aber zum wochenende gibt
es viele schauer teilweise auch gewitter
vor allen dingen am sonntag
jetzt schauen wir uns nochmal den
temperatur trend für münchen an in den
nächsten 14 tage zum wochenende geht es
also richtig runter
danach allerdings steigen die
temperaturen nächste woche wieder und
dann könnte so mitte september die
temperatur bei 22 grad liegen wollen
erstmal abwarten ich wünschen einen
schönen abend und machen sie es gut